les 4 mai quatre personnes qui vont dire
vos quatre vérités alors n'allez pas
savoir de qui il s'agit de qui vont
parler on va en accueillir une 1re c'est
parti premières personnes à bord et bas
très bas très bien merci alors on va
démarrer
on a démarré avec peter comment ça va
peter parce que à un moment ils vont
dire ils vont parler chacun d'un
chroniqueur on dire pourquoi ils ne
l'aiment pas et ce qui le dérange c'est
que des gens n'aiment pas exactement
alors il va ouvrir sa chemise à votre
avis lui quelques chroniqueurs nm par
peter dille attention peter hufschmied
et il ya le nom du chroniqueur qu'il
n'aime pas jacques gounon
valérie 8 heures est ce que tu vas dire
ses quatre vérités à bali est bénigne
c'est un vrai téléspectateurs de tp déjà
je la trouve un peu hypocrite en fait
c'est là où il échoue été calculée comme
toujours pour avoir une émission tu veux
présenter plus tard ne t'inquiète pas on
la regardera pas
dans la vie peter je travaille dans la
grande distribution d'accord et tu te
tapes d'un problème avec valérie bon
c'est pas un problème ce surplus
télévisuelle en quoi donc tu te colle
elle était bien en noir et blanc la
couleur n'a peut-être même pas valérie
pourquoi mais je la trouve hypocrite en
fait c'est juste ça et critique jamais
pour eux voient la pelouse pour moi
c'est calculé en fait d'accord alors
malik série je sais pas quoi traitement
de passe kerry bonne aventure et
voudront une mesure très critiquée
jusque producteurs violence de toi je
vais pas te critiquer parce que je ne te
connais pas donc en revanche moi je fais
mon métier comme je pense devoir le
faire et je travaille si jamais les
choses et tu dis que je suis hypocrite
et que je ne crache pas c'est ma pas ma
nature de clash et donc je vais pas
faire semblant pour faire plaisir à
certains qui aimerait qu'il y ait de
larmes et du sang tout le temps on est
dans une ère de télévision où les gens
veulent qu'ils aient des ddd des flashs
constant que l'on tire à vue qu'on dise
du mal et est prêt à faire dûment des
gens moi je suis tout le temps dans la
nuance mais dans ma vie je suis dans la
nuance
je dis les choses alors j'aime ça vous
faire de la peine ce qui vous a dit ban
s'est jamais agréable de que quelqu'un
vous dit je ne vous connais pas que tu
qu'ils vous aiment pas oui mais en
l'occurrence je peux comprendre parce
que moi il ya des gens que je ne connais
pas que j'aime pas parce que balader
luxation de la rotule aime bien regarder
la gamme
de la torre jonathan votre avis quelle
chroniqueur il n'aime pas dire il les
moyens
j'ai le maxi 1000 matchs il vous pensez
mathieu maintenant on attend gilles
c'est ma raison
matthieu delormeau aller dans la famille
des savates est plus petit mais choisis
je vois de cassel alors comment tu
t'appelles jonathan jonathan mon chéri
tu viens de fontenay pour demander
j'aime bien ton style
mais vraiment je te fais un bisou on
dirait office de manu payet mois alors
tu donnes pas mathieu non pas du tout
nonoban on va à travers l'écran il quand
même où il dégage à côté légèrement
méprisant part aux gants
il faut on voit à travers la télé quand
même été assez méprisant envers eux
mêmes les nouveaux arrivants c'est quand
même assez dommage quand on sait ce
pourquoi tu as quitté provisoirement tpm
paix je trouve que peut-être pas
tellement légitime
moi je te fuis comme ça et moi là moi à
mon sens aussi je trouve que tu n'as pas
tellement grand chose à faire autour de
la table je pense qu'au tour de table il
n'est que des professionnels des médias
tu ne te sens pas de trop
[Applaudissements]
les gars je ne le sont pas ce sont des
gens qui disent adeptes sont déjà vérité
qui lisent leur vérité n'est pas
terminée vignery il faut quand même
remettre dans son contexte que tu es
plus connu sous le nom de khadr pour
avoir montré tard et que pour que pour
de leurs mots pour tes analyses médias
donc je voulais juste savoir ça avec toi
alors déjà je suis pas chargé nathan
merci de ta question de la table parce
que pour mes analyses médias en effet
mais parce que syrie avait besoin aussi
de personnes connues notamment de
différents continents et de star jamie
bell et ya aussi des célébrités
bon je suis d'accord après pour le reste
pour le côté aussi arrogant méprisant et
tout ça c'est très souvent du second
degré jonathan mais le second degré est
une chose qui livrait avec
l'intelligence ce que je voulais juste a
ajouté c'est grâce au capteur de jean
luc lemoine on a appris du coup que tu
ne saluaient jamais les équipes
techniques ou très peu n'oublie pas
qu'une sans elle tu ne serais pas dans
la lumière mon fils pour finir et après
je passe là le micro à mes camarades
une assist grâce à jean luc j'ai appris
je ne saurais rien par hasard que tu
n'assistait pas aux répétitions
je répète révision bref tu n'en as pas
besoin c'est vrai puisque de toute
manière on te demande uniquement
d'imiter johnny donc au pire des cas
john en tout cas c'est lundi de john woo
[Applaudissements]
regard des perspectives dans la vie me
regarde je suis coach beauté bien-être
je bénis ça alors ça va bien votre avis
qui elle déteste à l'elysée les filles
tel est le pari aller mieux kelly à la
lettre entre nous non mais c'est rien ah
oui c'est vrai oui alors on ne monte pas
dire a dit alors pour toi sarko n'avait
pas géré dit prenez bien votre micro
pour ça c'est bon c'est moi tu peux y
aller alors pourquoi j'aime pas
géraldine j'irais pas jusqu'a dire que
je vous aime pas parce que je vous
connais pas je vous connais pas mais je
vais je vais vous dire un peu ce que
vous dégagez à travers l'écran en tout
cas pour ma part j'ai trouvé une
personne ultra sympathique à votre
arrivée vous étiez très sympathique très
souriante j'ai trouvé vous avez apporté
cette fraîcheur à la mission d'accord et
vous ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
entre temps et maintenant j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une giral jean pull
tracé vert ont fait penser même je suis
désolé on joue la franchise vous ne
faites même pensé à ma cpe aubin j'adore
les cpe
[Applaudissements]
voilà en tout cas la mienne je l'adoré
pas maintenant on je suis désolé mais je
vais revenir aussi sur ce que vous aviez
dit concernant puisqu'on a bien compris
que vous étiez anti télé réalité ouais
ouais on a bien compris
fatou fall et les réalités pas tout
téléréalité par exemple mais beaucoup
aller très vite parfait donc juste juste
je vous dirais que vos propos ont choqué
je vais pas revenir là dessus je vaux
proprement choqué et clairement il faut
savoir que ces gens là aujourd'hui
et bien pour moi en tout cas c'est quand
même un métier ça devient un métier gens
là ils font vivre
ils vont vivre d'aidés non vraiment ce
que vous pensez de gérald bibot on
voulait donc elle est trop haute ehn
pour la halle et rod n est pour moi
franchement vous taclez trop comme lala
d'infos avec agathe aussi sans en parler
trop c'était trop salé rabat ça m'a fait
énormément dit ce que je pense a tous
commencé en plus en disant je te
considère comme ma fille c'était
vraiment de talent fallait considérer
bien quand vous êtes cpe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes très bon mourad alors mourad
n'aime pas quelqu'un
[Rires]
[Musique]
pourquoi tu n'aimes pas maxime quoi ça
c'est clair
à côté parce que tout simplement pour
moi personnellement j'attends le haut en
tout cas ça ne change pas comme s comme
tu es ce qui par merci max in-game moi
je peux pas de berry maxime dennis
hopper est comme ca laconique c'est
sincère non mais parce que justement pas
tes scoop sont faibles petit immoraux et
immoraux pour moi c'était monsieur
scouts médias
et toi tu l'a remplacé et
malheureusement c'est pas trop ça
justement pas attendre raison tu te
plaît mais te dire que également il ya
trois-quatre jours la sortie un scoop
lequel il était le dire comme c'était
pour toi c'est je pense quitter ton
scoop de teint jours de la journée de la
semaine et s'est découvert les hélicos
voilà savoir que daisy cours vont
survoler la picardie l'auvergne
justement pas m'emballer
je m'emballe heck
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'un poids devrait pas que la voix a ni
à me stresse de mental mais m'agace
m'énerve je te jure mêmes foot à y voir
une entente fini une orthophoniste ou un
coach vocal je te bats pas tu vas sortir
un billet cyril barça parce que
justement parce et c'est vraiment
agaçant ensuite c'est sans fin
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les aigles et susceptible qui dit alors
sa relation dans laquelle il y a
justement pas et moi moi je voudrais je
compte avoir comme pote ci arrive parce
que ta range tellement le coup bah oui
pourquoi pas mais quand tu fait de tes
frères
frérot je touche mon frère je te ment
pas ah ouais huit grands vie tu vois
c'est plein de gens semaine au gardien
tu tires a coûté des vies
il est vraiment charmant mars est
vraiment très mignonne plus je te mords
pas chez célibataire maxime lui fait
rien il reste sur sa chaise en plus
voilà bois il aboie des molosses j'aime
bien si la chose avait lé minium il a
l'air un peu jeune non pourquoi sa
classe et là je ne fais pas ça alors que
la maturité elle brode la gym et 23 ans
voilà tu as quel âge
cette année 28 mai lors de
l'anniversaire mardi c'est quoi le 28
ouais ah oui mais c'est gratuit mais
qu'est ce que j'en ai à [ __ ]
on fait un lien qui dénigrent un
chroniqueur en direct feelgood que brac
si maxime avec qui ce soir ont dit toute
la vérité
ouais on peut pas être aimé de tout le
monde laissez-moi répondre à moi moi je
les ai brisé quand même non mais c'est
vrai alors maxime aiach plaisir juste
avant il est très probable qu'ils se
croient au débat des primaires et de
vérité parfois c'est bête de nous
comparer avec les héros se conseille de
regarder ses news il est très bon dans
la matinale donc les stocks fait plus
tôt et qui leur a il assure
véritablement concernant les scoops eux
à l'esc ou plutôt tu sais très bien que
c'est pour les séquences pour faire rire
c'est cyril le prend on en rigole et sur
le truc de la carte aux trésors ina
j'imagine beaucoup de téléspectateurs
qui ne savait pas qu'il y avait des
nouveaux hélicoptères qui survolaient la
ville
fabre elle avait beaucoup qui le savait
pas mais coulage en matinée sur ma voix
je demande valeur voit juste pas ton
look donc
et c'est le fils du professeur tournesol
et ça c'est dur quand on voit un kelly
son numéro c'est le 06 08
elle va habiter s'est abattue et voilà
vraiment petite soeur chichi tati je
vous aime at il à ces lieux et je
reviens vite pour mon anniversaire parce
que je suis venu exprès pour te clasher
anniversaire des attentats il faut juste
pas tout sur deux langues
je veux juste te dire un truc première
télé j'ai déjà un prime
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs
les bornes
[Applaudissements]
la panique est ce qui me bouffe